all right Sandra let's bring in Dave
ribbon the host of the ribbon report on
YouTube uh Davis to this idea that the
migrants were being misled about where
they were going the only thing I saw was
that the migrants who had dropped off at
the Naval Observatory today thought that
they were going to Union Station it
might have been turned uh you know uh
this idea that this is becoming
increasingly political that Greg
Abbott's busting migrants to the gates
of the Naval Observatory DeSantis is
flying them to Martha's Vineyard Lori
Lightfoot the mayor of Chicago is busing
the league of Myers from downtown
Chicago to a republican suburb of Burr
Ridge the mayor of El Paso was busing
them to New York City but nobody's
complaining about that I mean it's
getting Beyond political but you can't
get away from the fact that more than 2
million people have crossed the border
and that something's got to give here
right so let's deal with that part first
um two million people crossing the
border that is the job of the federal
government so if we're just looking
where do you lay blame first forgetting
whether you think people should go to
Sanctuary cities or not or whether it's
okay to bus people or put them on planes
number one everyone has to understand if
we're looking for who started this
problem it is 100 the Biden
Administration no matter what John Corin
Pierre says it is their job as the
federal government to protect our
borders that's number one number two as
for what's now happening where they're
bouncing across you know state lines and
into different cities and all that I
actually think this is quite good
because it is bursting forth the
fundamental difference between Democrat
policies and Republican policies I am a
very proud new Floridian and I love the
fact that Ron DeSantis warned the
federal government he warned the Biden
Administration what he was going to do
he said if they come here or say he said
we're sending them to DC or Martha's
Vineyards well he did Martha's Vineyard
and I suspect will send them to dc2
Texas is doing the exact same thing
you're seeing States say okay if the
federal government will not do their job
one of the few things the federal
government is supposed to do which is
protect our borders then hey go ahead
and go to these Sanctuary cities and
it's really funny too because the
Democrats are freaking out now that and
the media is freaking out that they're
showing up in Martha's Vineyard and
these and Chicago and other democrat-run
cities but it's like don't you guys care
about immigrants I thought everybody's
welcome nobody's illegal
etc etc although now DC's uh their
homeless shelters are being overrun by
illegals so they're struggling too but
the point is that it's it's exposing the
nonsense of the policies and I think
that's good yeah these cities call
themselves Sanctuary cities and yet when
the people seeking Sanctuary come there
they're not particularly happy about it
Abbott sent the bus right to the Naval
Observatory after Kamala Harris said
this over the weekend and Meet the Press
listen to this
border is secure but we also have a
broken immigration system in particular
over the last four years before we came
in and it needs to be fixed we're gonna
have two million people cross this
border for the first time ever you're
confident this border is secure
we have
a secure border
in that that is a priority for Any
Nation so she insists on multiple
occasions there that the border is
secure but listen to what a migrant from
Venezuela who came on one of those buses
to the Naval Observatory told our Griff
Jenkins just this morning
vice president Harris uh said that the
border is closed is the Border closed do
you believe that the border is closed or
is it open it's open not close your body
is open the border is open do you
believe that all the migrants believe
that the border is open yeah everybody
believes that their body is open it's
open because we enter we come in free
no problem how did you learn that the
Border was open to come illegally how
did you learn to come because we sit on
the news that everybody coming illegally
so we actually do the same you know so
what that migrant said to Griff Jenkins
would seem to stand in sharp
contradiction to what the vice president
claimed Dave
yeah look I'm sympathetic to that guy's
plight and if the news in where he's
coming from wherever whatever country
he's coming from is telling him hey The
Border's open and then everyone's going
the borders open and then he gets here
and the borders open thus he is in
American territory well then who's
telling the truth is it him who's here
now illegally or is it Kamala Harris she
has one job she seems incapable of doing
it she refuses to visit the border and
you know look a nation is only a nation
she she blamed Trump in essence she said
the previous four years uh Donald Trump
wanted to build a wall and remember what
everybody said when he wanted to build a
wall and and you know put up electric
fences and monitoring all that everyone
said he was racist so is it now the
policies of the Democrats who apparently
are very pro-border uh are they racist
now of course not so again we're
exposing a lot of the hypocrisy in the
policies and I think this should just
continue let's you know I think this
Martha's Vineyard the the area there
they just put out a warning about the uh
the influx of people and it's like
that's 50 people who just showed up on
those planes what do you think has been
going down at the Texas border towns for
years and years they didn't have a lot
of sympathy then no clearly they didn't
Dave great to get your thoughts on this
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else